following the principles in the 4-hour
chef can improve one's life even if they
have no interest in food because it's
really a cookbook for learning disguised
as a cookbook for food so somewhat like
zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance in that respect and as it
turns out the kitchen is the perfect
place the perfect dojo for human
potential and exploring all of the
avenues by which you can improve
learning because you engage all the
senses and I was not only a non cook but
an anti cook for my whole life and until
I watched my girlfriend show me how to
cook by having me smell different things
and tell her if they went together it
really opened my eyes to how much could
be done in the kitchen that applied
outside of the kitchen my readers have
been asking me for a book on learning
accelerated learning for five years now
and the problem is that writing about
learning in the abstract is really
boring to write and it's also really
boring to read so I needed a vehicle for
teaching all these things that I've
experimented with since college whether
that's you know smart drugs or language
learning or what have you and cooking
because I feared it for so long ended up
being the perfect starting point because
I could take people from ground zero
being really insecure really fearful to
really feeling completely self-reliant
in the kitchen and all of the bumps in
the road all the lessons learned
throughout and what I hope people take
from it at the end of the day is
believing wholeheartedly that they can
be come world-class ie
top 5% in the world in one or two things
per year not one or two things per
lifetime because I think that the 10,000
hour rule applies in certain places but
not all places and what I've had a lot
of fun doing is seeking out the
anomalies not just where the group's
condensed but looking for the really
unusual anomalies somebody who learns
Icelandic in seven days well enough to
go on TV and be interviewed someone who
can memorize it has trained himself to
memorize a deck of cards in 43 seconds
no matter how you shuffle it with no
real natural gift someone who learns to
become a world-class swimmer at age 38
these anomalies and then looking for the
recipe right the step by step
it produces results over and over and
over again that those people use sort of
identifying and distilling the recipe so
other people can apply it and I've just
found that food is a great way to
explore all that because even if you
never make a single recipe if you learn
to engage with food your experience of
every meal you have goes from black and
white good bad hot cold to HD and a
million colors and that is a really
really fun experience at the end but I
want people to take all of those things
they've put on the Shelf like I can't
swim
right I couldn't swim until a few years
ago I can't ever play basketball because
I was personally humiliated by a junior
high
coach way back in the day said I
dribbled like a caveman so it's like how
bad at basketball I could never do it
take those things off the shelf or
playing the guitar whatever it is those
those skills you've retired and to
really tackle them and become extremely
extremely good at the macro goal of the
book is really to instigate a super
trend a macro trend and at least
according to people like Mark Bittman
for whom I have a lot of respect of the
New York Times formerly of the
minimalist column you really need about
20 million people to do that and we're
at a point in this country where roughly
50% I believe of the independently owned
farms are going to be up for grabs
people are retiring and so whether that
land goes to strip malls goes to a huge
Agrico
or stays in a smaller more sustainable
farm is going to be determined by how we
vote three times a day by eating and so
the goal is not to sell 20 million books
I'd be great don't get me wrong but is
to change how 20 million people think
about food even if that means looking at
their breakfast differently and at least
based on the last two books I think
that's entirely achievable so I'm very
very optimistic but I think we need to
move from a few enormous food suppliers
to many smaller food suppliers if we
really want to have a sustainable
future